hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar the
impact of sars kobe 2
genomic surveillance locally nationally
and globally
i am michelle ashton of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths
and brought to you by thermo fisher
scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question
box and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical issues here as
well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
there has been a slight change to our
agenda today i'd like to now welcome our
first speaker
dr jared alcare associate dean of
professional program
and graduate affairs northeastern
university
and joining him today dr nicola normano
director of the cell biology and
biotherapy unit
and translational research development
national cancer institute
in naples jared and nicolas welcome you
may now begin your presentations
great thanks for that introduction um i
won't belabor
the title slide except to say that i've
listed my email address here and please
don't hesitate to drop me an email if
you have questions or
want to talk about anything further
northeastern is a
wonderful university that's all about
collaboration and partnership so
definitely feel free to do that at any
time
of course just briefly i'm going to show
the disclaimer slide i won't read it to
you because we've all seen these slides
many times but
this is just the disclaimer
all right so first i thought i'd start
by telling you a little bit about
northeastern university in boston
massachusetts
often times when i travel inside
northeastern people are like you mean
northwestern
uh no i mean northeastern university in
boston
massachusetts in the great state of
massachusetts we're a top 50 university
we are an r1 research university
according to
the carnegie carnegie standards
our career services has been ranked
number one several years
running we are a global campus that has
a global network of campuses
in boston in burlington in
portland maine san francisco
internationally in london and
toronto and vancouver our claim to fame
if you're familiar with northeastern at
all
is experiential education so our
signature co-op program
youth inspired work inspired research
and training is at the heart of what we
do
and we have approximately 5 000 faculty
and staff and
28 000 students or so
in the context of what northeastern
doesn't have which is particularly
important to think about in the context
of what i'll talk to you about today
is we have no medical school or clinical
labs
in our history we had been considered a
commuter school until maybe about 20
years ago when
we really pivoted to a top-notch
research and education institution but
still no medical school or clinical labs
we do have the bouve college of health
sciences that does nursing
and other clinical activities but no
clinical labs or medical schools
so what i thought i would do is start by
telling you
the journey of how a university with no
medical school
pivoted to respond to the covid19
pandemic
in 2020 and
how it's evolved since the program
started
um so many months ago at this point it
feels like an eternity but really it's
only been what
about a year so briefly
i broke it down into a sort of a
timeline of events
and i'll break these down as i go
through
the presentation slowly but you can see
that you know
just like the rest of the world on march
13th the university
decided to deliver all of its
educational content
fully remote this day will always stick
out in my mind because that week of
march 9th i was
providing a training program to a number
of international regulators from africa
and kept thinking to myself every day
please don't close the university
because i have to finish the program
and get these folks home and we did
finish the program and luckily
they were able to get the last flight
out of the airport back to africa
and the second the university closed a
couple weeks later we sent home
all of our students and then started
planning for the reopening in the fall
right we wanted to make sure that we
opened safely and that
entailed a number of different steps
along the way
you know instituting a reopening task
force and then what i'll focus on here
is
exactly the result of what that task
force decided
which was to start our own testing lab
back in the day when they asked me if i
would help them do this i thought it was
like everything else in my life i'm
naive and said yeah no problem we could
do that
that's going to be easy which of course
it was not
so on march 13th like i mentioned we
went to remote instructions
a couple of weeks later all university
students and employees
were fully remote and not on campus
research continued throughout the whole
entire pandemic which i think is
important to know
especially that related to tsar's cough
2
and then um you know so in essentially
two days
everything that was happening at the
university that was converted to online
which is
as you know both rapid and
necessary
so then you know the next few weeks the
university formulated a reopening
committee
which was made up of the senior
leadership and other key stakeholders
that reopening committee was monitoring
the current situation in massachusetts
and across the globe since we have
campuses everywhere and out of that
reopening committee
came a testing task force which is where
my
initial role came into play
so from the very beginning the testing
task force had a four-prong
strategy to look at best options partner
with large diagnostic labs to do testing
monitor new technologies partner with
other
academic institutions or set up our own
testing lab you know we we realized to
open safely in the fall of 2020 we would
have to have testing as part of our
daily activities or what the norm would
be for this academic year
and these are the four things that we
consider in the process
we learned pretty quickly that
partnering with large diagnostic labs
was going to be
a challenge the turnaround time at the
time you know this point in time in
april of 2020
was variable the medicaid or medicaid
was dictating the price of what those
test costs
and would only allow for one test per
person
to be paid for so that that limited our
options
so um that was some of those challenges
there
you know thinking about new technologies
one of them in particular that we meant
we might
be monitored for testing was next
generation sequencing
which i'll talk about in a little more
detail about how we use that
now in a little bit but at the time
there was no fda approved euas for ngs
and the timeline and scalability was
unclear so
those were a few challenges around and
gs is a new technology we did monitor a
number of other
new technologies such as antibodies and
antigen tests again they were a little
bit further behind
we did look at partnering with other
academic institutions in the boston area
for testing
most of them had medical schools so
boston university has a medical school
the broad institute is has clinical labs
and this is part of harvard and mit
et cetera right and it's northeastern
had no medical school
um we were in a unique situation so
we didn't partner with any of the big
schools because they were all doing
their own thing
we did consider helping some of the
smaller schools around us
um but in the end weren't able to do
that
so then we decided that the best
approach with the least
amount of challenges and risk was
developed
creating our own testing labs which is
the life sciences testing center
and from memorial day until july 12th
we had further discussions about whether
that actually should happen or not it
wasn't a good
return our investment and on july 12th
we got the final final
final final green light to start
processing
paperwork and get the lab set up
while we were doing that obviously like
i mentioned one of the things we had to
consider was what type of test to
institute
we were only considering at the time
molecular diagnostic or pcr based tests
or serological testing we of course
decided to use molecular diagnostic
testing because it
is the gold standard in testing
and most sensitive and most
specific so that's what we decided to do
the life science testing center was born
on june 12th like i mentioned
we have no medical school or clinical
lab so i was starting from scratch it
was
me who was asked to get up the center up
and running
we had to decide where to locate it and
if you've ever been to boston you'll
know that
space is limited on the boston campus in
boston in general
we have a regional campus in burlington
massachusetts which is about 20 miles
northwest of boston i had a lab there
already that i had just
finished construction on new lab space
okay i didn't do the construction
clearly but
the construction on the new lab space
had just finished so i had four walls
that were set up to be a lab that had
nothing in them
we sort of hijacked that space to get
the testing lab
up and running which was about uh
3 900 square feet or so we hired south
shore lab consultants a great consulting
agency that helped us set up our clio
lab by providing standing operating
procedures and a number of other things
enter including vetting
cvs of employees to make sure they fit
all the guidelines that we needed them
to
for me when i think about testing when i
think about anything that i do
at the heart of it is the patients which
in this case would be our student body
or
employees and ensuring quality and
accurate
results so quality and accuracy are the
foundation of everything we do
so with that at the foundation we just
determined what kind of tests to use
nasopharyngeal interior nair
saliva or other we had to acquire the
appropriate equipment
hire and train staff select the
laboratory information system which one
would have thought would have been easy
but was much more complicated than i
hoped determine the sample flow secure
the testing supplies
the consumables and disposables do the
validation and get certified obviously
supply chain was crunched for most of
these things at the time
that supply chain crunch doesn't exist
so much anymore except maybe in the
plastics but
that was a huge challenge at the
beginning and this was all
um a challenge that we faced
one of the things that was super
important to me was picking the right
test right we i already told you
we're going to go pcr but what kinds of
tests were we going to use i looked at
the cdc test
i wasn't and i'm still not a huge fan of
it it monitors one gene
um on the viral genome it largely had
been
only the n1 primer the n2 and m3 have
been set aside although n2 is being used
more
routinely again so you know to me that's
not a good n there's not enough
reproducibility if you will so we looked
for tests that would allow us to monitor
several
different genes i did my phd research in
a drug resistance lab so
for hiv so i understood very well how
viruses
rna viruses mutate and evolve clearly
knowing that they want to
remain in existence and not kill their
host so from the very beginning i was
concerned about
variance and what that might look like
so i wanted to monitor more than one
gene
across the genome which is why we landed
on attack path topic 19 combo kit
monitoring or 1ab the s gene and
the engine and the s gene will be an
important thing as we go through
some of the later points that i'll make
sample workflow just like anything else
we set this up in june sample collection
you know sample prep using liquid
handling robots pcr and data analysis
nothing special there
so from june 12th or so to july 31st
about six weeks we set up the lab
installed all the instruments did all
the qualifications hired
the staff went through the whole process
and on july 31st
had our inspection by the state of
massachusetts in our
original clia registration and were
approved for processing tests that day
the testing sites were set up those were
sample collection sites on our boston
campus
one for asymptomatic patients so the
cabot testing center was for
routine surveillance testing or medical
screening
we test students every three days
employees twice a week if they're on
campus about five days a week this
hunting contesting center was a
symptomatic site
i can tell you i learned a really great
example all of our modeling has
suggested that we will be receiving 200
samples a day
on our first day of actually processing
patient samples which was
middle of august and at 1 pm
1300 samples arrived on our doorstep
which we were not ready for i wanted to
scale
hundreds to thousands not thousands in
the middle of the day and we were
closing at 7 p.m
and so you know that was definitely a
challenge we had to overcome
and luckily we did
so this is what we landed on and swabs
the samples are transported from boston
to the lab
all of our tester medical tests are
ordered by a physician
when students return to campus like i
mentioned they were tested on day one
day three and day five before they go
back to class
and then they were tested every three
days that continues through
the end of this academic year so may of
21 first week of may of 21
employees are tested every five days and
the testing
is for students employees and
contractors who were
embedded in the university
so at the time we had these equipment
just highlighting quickly
eight biological safety cabinets seven
liquid handlers nine qpcr
machines approximately 75 clinical staff
i did realize we needed support staff
because like i said we have no medical
solar infrastructure
so we brought on a lab manager to
er excuse me a supply chain manager to
handle supply chain i was spending a lot
of my time dealing with that
qa qc to ensure the quality of
everything we did
i.t lab information manager and a
business manager
and we went from operating 12 hours a
day to 24 7 365.
shortly after that we expanded the lab
space another 1300 square feet and
increased our capacity
to about 15 to 20 000
samples per day
we also did receive irb approval for
research so we have a research
repository in registry
you know we want to understand copa 19
and learn how we might prevent the next
pandemic
it's also a really interesting thing as
i'm sort of talking about the
northeastern testing program which is
a sort of a local program and and really
can give us a proxy for what might be
happening in the community around
northeastern and boston
but also really highlights the need for
for my in my opinion a larger scale
network of
infrastructure for for testing moving
forward
so as i mentioned in the expansion we
doubled our size
and doubled our instrumentation and then
started to consider testing beyond
northeastern to
use some of that capacity if it was
possible
which it was we started doing k-12
testing
just about mid-march beginning of march
to help you know the primary school kids
get back to school
so looking at our four-prong strategy
partnering with large diagnostic labs
didn't work out we still continue to
monitor new technologies
and uh i will consider partnering with
other institutions and clearly have our
own testing lab that's operating
and are thinking about kova testing and
and
other tests we might do in the future
and research opportunities
we are transitioning to pool testing uh
over the next month
or so we're looking at how we might
support serological testing
and other um sort of vaccine passport
related tests
including you know we didn't really have
a flu season this past year because of
mask wearing which is great
but one would anticipate having uh
respiratory diseases
increase in prevalence in the population
as as we go into the next
flu season and common cold season
so we might have a bunch of symptoms and
we don't know what is what what disease
it is so we're looking at combination
tests like flu covered and
other respiratory combo kids
so briefly i just want to transition to
phase two of our timeline which was in
january right now that's where we
started
you know the vaccine started coming on
board in in or online in december
we started hearing much more about
variants and
started to determine how we were going
to
leverage our testing program to monitor
those variants of concern
both from an isolation and safety
standpoint as well as
potential information that we could
learn by the large number of samples
that we collect
so the population began to get
vaccinated like i mentioned and we
started hearing about variance concern i
just listed a few of them here that
you know we we had thought about from
that january time frame and continue to
think about like the uk variant b117
b1351 the south african variant p1 in
brazil and others
that we monitor currently to see
what's happening right one of my things
as we move into the summer and the fall
is more people become vaccinated at the
university set up our
test testing infrastructure that we
continue to monitor vaccinated people if
at all possible
so that a variance of concerns start to
become predominant for whatever reason
especially as international students
come back in fall of 21 for the next
academic year
we're prepared and can be proactive
instead of having to be
reactive so i think it's an important
thing for us to monitor also it could
add
tremendous amounts of data and value to
understanding
the evolution and of disease
variance in populations and how we might
prevent it
so we we do have next generation
sequencing
um as part of the infrastructure here at
northeastern uh it's in my
biopharmaceutical analysis and training
lab so not technically part of the
testing center
variance you know cause us to developing
develop the sequence strategy obviously
like i mentioned we use the starters the
starscop2 cactas kit which has
orf1a1b n-gene and s-gene
we started seeing a large number of s
gene dropouts
which are we had predicted and
hypothesized for due to b117
so we decided to sequence those
positives in collaboration with the
state of massachusetts department of
public health and on our own
and over a three week period in march we
were seeing about five percent of our
samples being s-gene dropouts
which was confirmed by sequencing and
over the next several weeks that five
percent went to fifty percent
uh that went to eighty five percent um
confirmed by sequencing and um
other uh varying panel use
so we saw that the number of our
positive cases
increased drastically as b117 circulated
our population and
over the last several weeks or since
then
those numbers have come way down and our
positivity rate right now is
less than 0.1 percent we get you know
far fewer
positive tests which also is a reason to
remind people it's important to remain
vigilant
uh as time goes on because the summer of
course with windows open and people
outside we would
expect fewer infections anyways
so currently we're using a multi-prong
approach
to our testing
protocols the traditional testing where
we can
identify a positive or negative using
the qpcr that we've been using all along
sending s gene dropouts to
pcr using variant panels
to identify specific variants quickly
and then
sequencing those using next generation
sequencing as well as
sequencing all of our positives new and
banked to see
what exactly the sequence of those
viruses are so this is currently what
we're doing
in a multi-prong approach to keep our
community safe
and to understand more about thesaurus
cop2
virus and pandemic
so briefly i think i learned a lot of
things over the last year
it's been a really exciting and
stressful time setting up a clio
certified lab in six weeks as you know
or might imagine but i would really
promote continued testing especially
of unvaccinated people but also a
vaccinated individual to identify
vaccine escape variants so we can be
more proactive versus reactive like i
said
we have seen three vaccinated
individuals who
are fully vaccinated so eight weeks post
their last vaccine shot that tested
positive for coping one of them was
tested outside the university so i don't
have access to that sample
one of those samples was recent and
we're currently
doing further analysis on that using the
workflow that i showed previously with
the variant
panels and next generation sequencing
and one of those we analyze
an initial round and we're able to
determine that
the variant is either p1 or b1 351
we're doing more analysis to suck that
out
you know next generation sequencing to
me is crucial in identifying new
variants
the ones that i know about concern me
less than the ones that i don't know
about in terms of variants so i'm really
interested in learning what those are
there's an opportunity for research
how we can really help progress next
generation sequencing
into a routine diagnostic tool for
example
so it's faster it's reliable for sure
but faster and more robust in the early
days one of the reasons we didn't
consider ngs
the turnaround time was a little slower
than we could do ourselves but i think
uh
crucial and um you know sequencing
in a pandemic but sequencing of viruses
in general i think is an important thing
to do
when we when we talk about the united
kingdom being
about you know 10 or sequence and the us
is about 1 and that's awful
10 is definitely better than 1 but i
think in general we can do better and
i'm really
hoping that we can drive that forward
and look forward to automated systems
helping with that that i know exists
and the last thing that i really want to
say is you know
lots of institutions invested lots of
time and resources and setting up
clinical labs and setting up different
testing and diagnostic resources
from a national perspective it's really
a time
to think about what a national
testing infrastructure or pandemic
response
might be or you could even think about
it if you want to loop it into
a category of sort of biosecurity
uh in general that doesn't mean warfare
right but i'm talking security against
pandemics and other things that might
happen so
it's our opportunity for some sort of
national infrastructure to be set up and
maintained
clearly not at the level that it is but
maintained
through partnerships with individual
universities and
other entities spearheaded through large
companies and government so that we have
those in a network that can
help respond in the future and with that
i am thank you for your time and
attention
and like i mentioned please feel free to
email me if you have any questions
or comments and happy to answer a few
questions now
but many thanks for inviting me to give
this talk on negro pathology activities
in the covenanting era these are
my disclosures and this is an additional
disclaimer
from term official centric well in the
first part of my talk i will briefly
describe you the
impact of cognitive pandemic emergency
on
currency research activities in italy
then i will
discuss some results from literature
related to the activities of molecular
pathology labs during the lockdown i
will try also
to show you some possible solutions
in situation reduced personnel in the
lab
and finally i'll touch a little bit on
the possible rule of molecular pathology
labs
in the sequencing of subscription viral
let's start see to see first what
happened
in italy in labs involving cancer
research
during the lockdown as you might know in
march and april
2020 in italy we had almost complete
lockdown
of the country and in may 2020 the
italian cancer society launched this
survey
in order to assess really what happened
during lucknow in
the labs involved in cancer research the
survey was completed by
170 researchers belonging to almost all
european regions and the first question
that we
asked to the participant is what
happened in your lab did your lab
suspend
the research activity during the
covenant in emergency and actually 48
percent
out participating declared that the
activities were completed uh suspended
whereas the partial suspension was
supported by 36 percent
of the participant and no suspension
from 16 percent of participants
of course the main impact of lochna
was on face-to-face research activities
that was
significant reducing most of the cases
and this was in part compensated by the
use of smart working and still now
we are using smart work in some italian
labs in order to reduce
the number of researchers that are
present in the lab at the same time thus
reducing the possibility of spread of
the banks
[Music]
in uh the lockdown
about 30 percent of italian researchers
were involved in a
research project they're related to
covenanting and approximately the same
fraction was also involved
in other activities like testing swabs
or other
that were also related to the covenant
is
thus underlie you know
the willingness of italian researcher to
help in a situation of emergency
like the pandemic that we are still
facing
uh quite surprisingly after the lockdown
almost
20 percent of the researchers did not
resume yet
their activity and even more
surprisingly
in 28 of the research
that the return to work were not offered
any theological tests of swab whereas 21
of the researchers were not informed
about this means
that in almost 50 of the cases
no contingency plan was prepared in
order to ensure
that researchers could go back to work
in a safe environment
and because we are still in the in the
situation which
the virus is is spreading we still have
a high level of presence of infection
in our countries highlighting that these
data are real
data on which we should think about but
see now what happened to the activities
of molecular potential labs during
lockdown
in this respect we have some completing
results coming from the literature
this for example is a survey that was
performed in
several european thoracic pathology labs
and what it was uh
uh what was reported that when the
activities of march
may 2020 were compared to the activities
of march may 2018
only slight reduction in ngs in the
klingon technology
was observed uh slightly more reduction
was observed in
levy bapsi and in ngs testing
for calligraphs but clearly
more significant reduction was observed
for some specific tests like pcr
or fish analysis now this data
somehow in contrast with this report
that from that describes in
a similar survey in a number of italian
labs involving molecular pathology
what was reported in this study is that
the number of tests really did not
reduce significantly however there was a
clear shift from
ngs to more simple tests such as idylla
in molecular pathology labs with also
an induction in a turnaround time from
7.9 to 5.3
days so what happened in this in this
lab i mean
what the authors discussed is that in
many cases because of the reduced
number of uh research of these number of
personnel
present in the labs then the labs to
switch
from more complex tests to more simple
tests well i have to say
that in our lab we had no reduction told
our activity of clinical technology
clinical research
and these are the data for negative the
number
of tests that we performed are were
almost the same or
slightly increase in 2020 as compared to
2019
and actually contain use and jazz but
this is also due to the fact that
working academic centers we have a lot
of clinical terms available
and of course we have a request from our
colleagues to test patients for a number
of uh genomic alterations that offer the
potential to
erode patients in clinical trials this
is just the example for landing
carcinoma
actually as you may know the european
society of medical oncology
recently released the recommendation of
oranges testing solid tumors
and ismu recommends that in
the clinical practice you should use ngs
for lagadino casino carcinogen
prostate cancer ovarian cancer calcium
primary few other applications actually
what
really there's no recommendation is to
use angiosperms that are
limited to genomic alterations that are
level one so basically
use genomic after issue that for which
there are approved treatments
however in the centers that have a
cleaner trust available it is
recommended
to use larger parts because if you use
larger parts you can
identify patients and might be enrolled
in a clinical trial based on
genomic alterations still if there is a
reduction in the number of personnel in
the lab it might be difficult to
continue
to test for ngs uh old patients but
a solution in this respect might be
represented by
automation and i have to say that the
genexo system
might represent really very good
solution for cleaning this
research in fact this is a nearly
automated system
that goes from nucleic acid purification
to library preparation of violent
uh sequencing by interpretation and
reporting
now the genetics is a very fast
system very easy to use with a very
limited
hands-on time and i think that uh
it's a dc represent a very good solution
to ensure an increase in level
automation in our lives
now there are many panels can be used on
genexus the uncommon position i say
is a panel that laser according to my
thinking uh very good for clinical
research in fact this
panel covers 50 genes and
all different types of genetic
alterations defeat these different genes
dna of transplantations carbon and
vibration as well as
fusions now this the panel of course is
based on the amplicic
technology and if you use an implicit
technology you are limited to identify
only known fusion because you know
must know the sequence of the the the
carriers and of course and of
the partner however the uh
uh oppa essay as this exon tiling
imbalances
that allows also the identification
of unknown fusions and at least this
assay is available for a number of
targets that are listed here
in the next few slides i will show you
and multisend this also over this
multi-center study for the evaluation
of the uh oncoming precision engine of
genexus
this study was run in four different
labs part of basel chattanooga and
malabi nipples
each of these labs selected a number
of symbols that were already
characterized by using
different techniques these were either
fb or plasma symbols
and these symbols were tested for a
number of genomic alterations
these slides shows uh the types of
symbols that we tested
most from lung cancer but also
colon cancer and other tumor types were
tested
the uh cellularity of these samples
ranged from
10 percent to almost 100 percent
these are the variants that were
identified in this study in the symbols
that we tested
and all different types of studying or
different genes and here have shown
some actual genomic history that are
relevant for therapeutic intervention
as shown in this slide we called
identified
variants at different allelic
frequencies
and also violence at a little frequency
as low as 2.79 percent
thus confirming the high sensitivity of
the ampsig technology
when we compare the results of the
opacity with the previous testing
to concordance range between 94 and 100
with the specificity of 490 percent so i
would say
very good results quite a few copy
number variation
present in symbols that we analyzed and
they were detected by
the opa acid but also confirmed by
previous testing
and uh more importantly we could
identify this simple 29
different disorder are fusion isoforms
and as shown here we identify fusions of
fgfr
art red and track methox of forty
scheming
genes all different types of fusions
among different fusions
we could also identify a novel arc
fusion
this fusion was identified thanks to
the imbalance essay and it was confirmed
by using official assay
the concordance with the previous test
was 96 percent
and finally we had also the chance to
test a number of
plasma symbols these trauma centers
contain
uh mutations at uh that almost 50
percent
of these plasma symbols contain
mutations at all frequencies that was
below five percent and uh as shown here
all different types of
digital identifier and when we compare
result
of the upper essay with the previous
testing
the concordance was uh for between 95
and 100 so in conclusion i mean
the uh these results suggest that uh
the angelic leucine and the alpha
uh show a very high performance in terms
of the
violence identification the concordance
the previous test was very very high
more importantly i'm saying that the
implementation
of the operation x was successful it was
very easy
you know for labs and we are really
happy now
to use this workflow in our clinical
research
and lastly slide i want to discuss on
the possibility
to sequence the source genome for
monitoring the evolution of violence
i'm not a biologist but i think that
everyone knows
that one of the issues that we need to
face is
the evolution of the genomic evolution
the subscribe to
virus evolution that is always ongoing
because of the
huge spread of the infection and also
because of the slowness
of the vaccination campaign now some of
these new violence might be of clinical
interest
because they might be associated with
increased ability of the virus to spread
or about to increase increased
resistance
or virus to antibodies or fluxes
now uh demofishing scientific has
available this uh
uh panel for uh saskatoon
genome uh sequencing uh this panel
contains actually these panels is four
by two poles with
247 amplicons aligning over 99
coverage of the source copter general
and this panel of course can be run on
different sequences
the s5 but also the genetics but if you
use the genex
the advantage is that the workflow is
very simple
and very fast so by using genexos it
might be possible you know
to test uh the samples in a few hours or
faster than one day and this might be
very important to for
to monitor the evolution of the virus
in particular situations now
we wanted really to to to test how
the genex was able really to sequence
the subscribe to
genome and for this reason we run this
small study in
20 with insecurities in sables from 27
patients
these patients were from the campaigns
and these blobs were collected in march
april 2020 so in the first phase
of the pandemic in italy and as shown
islam these patients had viable
vision and critical conditions from
asymptomatic to
uh intensive therapy unit
first thing that we did was to quantify
uh the
viral content of these symbols by using
reverse descriptors pcr
and we classified these symbols in two
groups 15 with a high virus title
more than 20 copies per microliter and
12 with the low value of title with less
than 20 carbons
migrated the symbols with the i viral
title where sequencing
use the subscribe to research essay
raise the samples with low diversitative
sequences
either the subscription locator research
essay on the genexis
these are the results the complete
genome
of the saskatchewan was successfully
obtained for
21 out of 27 symbols
i have to say however that in additional
three symbols
we had the number 95 uh coverage of
uh the saskatchewan the complete genome
was fully sequenced for the older all 15
samples with the
of title for two two symbols with
a viral genome copy number less than 200
but or
higher than 20 copies and also for four
out of 10 symbols that had a very low
viral load less than 20 copies per
microliter
in the 21 samples with the complete
genome
reconstructed we found 51
variants with the 29 nonsense mutation
and of these 2970 modulus mutation
seven were in the spike according to
phylogenetic analysis 17 over these
genomes belong to lineage b1 last four
sequencing belong to the hp
1.1 and i think that these data are in
agreement with
the types of violence they were
diffusing at the time which is perhaps
obtained we are continuing to test
patients in our institute and by doing
this a few weeks ago we could identify
for the first time later this violent be
one uh 525
that has been already described in about
100 cases
in other countries around the world
this band is of particular relevance
because contains a number
of mutations including the spike e
falling for
k mutation which has been associated
with resistance to antibiotic and
vaccine
and of course now we are monitoring the
inclusion of this parent
in our region so my conclusions
uh i showed you how the combination
pandemics give affected the activities
of research lab as well molecular
pathology labs
i do believe that automation molecular
pathology labs can be available in
conditions
of reduced personnel and in this respect
the high automated
genexo system can really simplify
laboratory
workflow and reduce eternal time the
data that we collect in
our study together with colleagues and
understandings suggest that the opapan
and non-genetics
really can guarantee inadequate genomic
profiling for cancer staples
and finally the rapid sequencing of the
subscribe to genome with each nexus
may facilitate multiple revolution
device
my very last slide is to 10 my
collaborators to colleagues at
the other bts site basel berlin and
porto
colleagues at the sigo superior descent
collaborative in the project from the
saskatchewan
genome testing and funny colleagues of
the
future scientific and of course i thank
you all for your attention
thank you jared nicola for your
informative presentations
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
all right let's take a look lots of
great questions coming in
here's our first question jared what
specific
learnings would you share with other
academic institutions
interested in establishing a campus-wide
testing and surveillance program
excellence great question um
you know i would i would say
first and foremost do your homework
and pay attention to what's happening
around you
you know the first step for for us was
setting up the lab to identify
positive and negative patient samples
and then to integrate that with next
generation sequencing as we move forward
in the pandemic genomic surveillance is
going to be
more important and more predominant so
you know setting those things up at once
and then
really it's a great exercise to keep a
campus safe and
making sure that the campus can remain
open
uh our testing currently will also
include
vaccinated people which i think is an
important thing to monitor
at least as we go through the fall
semester so um
you know we we're doing that also i mean
i set up the clay certified lab in
six weeks i wouldn't recommend that that
was uber
uber fast and stressful um
but you know i think um
taking advantage of what others have
done before you at this point is
is the best way to go
great thank you all right is
northeastern treating individuals with
specific
variants any differently than others
that test positive
and again another good question right
now we're
currently not treating individuals who
test
positive for a given variant any
differently than
our other patients who are
tested positive interestingly of course
as as we all are we're monitoring
closely the recommendations from
cdc and and elsewhere and
um and do see there is some data that
suggests some of the variants have an
infectious period longer than
quote unquote what while what people
might consider to be wild type
uh so those are part of our
conversations in terms of
isolating those people for a longer time
perhaps but as of right now
um we are not treating them any
differently
all right thank you all right your next
question
which area did you find difficult to
handle as compared to
others
yeah that's a really good question um
so i think you know one of the one of
the challenges for us that initially
right is a
university without a medical school and
now without any experience it was one
getting a research orientated university
to understand
what it means to function within a
regulated environment we can't just
change things
overnight obviously
now the challenge another challenge we
had was sort of
uh volume right we originally
when we plant we're starting to plan we
were thinking we processed 2 000 tests
per day and that
number drastically increased to max on
our busiest day is 7 000 tests per day
now we have capacity for 20 so we solved
for that but that was a challenge
um and then you know we should have
thought about
integrating genomic surveillance from
the very beginning
of the process i mean i i was thinking
about mutations from the very beginning
but was inundated with setting up the
the clia certification
itself we should have integrated that
much earlier so that we would have been
uh
further along in sequencing we
instituted that sort of in the january
time frame
or mid january time frame so we should
have thought about that before and
done that but einstein is 20 20 and
we're doing it now so
i guess that's all that matters
awesome thank you all right looks like
we have time for one
last question how are sharing sequencing
data with
public health organizations
yeah that's a great question so we share
our sequencing
information broadly speaking where we
will we share
we share our genomics surveillance data
or sequencing data with
the massachusetts department of public
health and we have a great line of
communication with them
because most of our samples are from
massachusetts obviously since that's
where the campus is or all of our
samples are actually from massachusetts
also we have an ongoing dialogue with
them and share that information with
them
um you know we also when we can
send them some samples of sequence on
their own
genomic surveillance platforms just for
confirmation
so that we can check each other so
really great interactions there with the
department of public health and in the
state of massachusetts for us
i'm sure the same elsewhere that allows
for these things to be monitored
at a state level as well in a national
level
all right well thank you again jared and
nicola for your time today
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our
sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions any
questions we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speakers via
the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labberts will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event
until next time goodbye